-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actor
and comedian you know
from "Saturday Night Live,"
which premieres
this Saturday on NBC and Peacock
with host Pete Davidson
and musical guest Ice Spice.
He also stars in
"Dicks: The Musical,"
which is in select theaters
now and nationwide October 20th.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend Bowen Yang,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Thank you. Thanks, Seth.
-You have not just "SNL."
You have one of my favorite
podcasts, "Las Culturistas."
-Oh, my goodness.
-And you took it on --
[ Cheers and applause ]
There we go. Give it up.
-You know, someone might
be on it soon.
-I can't wait.
You took it to Europe.
You did live shows in London
and Berlin and Amsterdam.
-Yes, yes.
Those are the big
expat markets, apparently.
-Yeah.
-It was really fun.
-We talked about Amsterdam.
I was doing shows
in Amsterdam in the summer.
I went back to Boom Chicago,
which is the theater
I used to work at.
And it's actually where
you did your live podcast.
-That's right, that's right.
-Did you do anything fun in
Amsterdam while you were there?
-We just walked the canals.
We took a boat,
and I love Amsterdam.
I went twice this summer.
I -- My only issue with it
is that it's tough
when you combine a city --
when you combine weed
with bicycles.
I feel like it's a recipe
for disaster.
Crossing the street
is really scary.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
It is not -- So you even --
You're not even saying
like being on a bicycle,
just being stoned
on foot is scary
because there's so many
bicycles.
-You don't have to be
the person who's stoned.
You might be next
to a stoned person,
and then they're the ones
who, like, causes a big,
like 10-person pileup
or something.
-A bike pileup.
-It is. I will say,
you have to do a lot wrong
for a car to come near you
on a bicycle in Amsterdam.
Like, the cars
are so aware of the bikes,
and that is very nice.
But I will say on foot,
sometimes you'll just walk
right into the path.
-That's right, that's right.
-And the Dutch people
are very --
I love them very much.
They are cold and unforgiving.
[ Laughter ]
-But that said with love.
-Yes.
Did you go to did you go
to any museums?
-I did. The hot ticket
is the Van Gogh Museum,
and concierge in my hotel
was very, very good
about getting me tickets.
And he did say to me,
"This is harder than getting
Taylor Swift tickets."
And I said,
"That can't be true."
[ Laughter ]
There's no way that's true."
And, like, you know,
there aren't, like, teen girls
fighting me for it,
so it's fine.
-There was I feel like a fight
to get into the Lincoln Center,
Las Culturistas Awards.
-Yes.
-You did that this --
Was it this summer?
-It was this summer, yes.
-And so one of our producers,
Henry, was there, and he said
there was literally two loops
around the block to get in.
-Yeah, that's pretty crazy.
It was a free show.
So that explains it.
-Yeah. Yeah. Free show.
But again, you were
giving out awards
and they were
the culture awards.
-That's right.
-And for people
who don't know the podcast,
you kind of give out
the sort of awards
that I feel like are overlooked
by a lot of
the main award shows.
-Absolutely.
-Like, for example,
you gave out the the Chris Award
for Most Timeless Name.
-Most Timeless Name.
[ Laughter ]
-The nominees were John,
Jess, George, Mark and Doja.
-Yeah, Doja. Doja Cat. Pretty
timeless name, I would say.
She did not win.
-Do you remember who won?
-Oh, this is a quiz.
-No, I didn't mean
to make it a quiz.
-That's okay.
-I was going to say it.
-Please.
-Jess.
-And why do you think --
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
This is literally
on a spreadsheet
and we just, like,
change the cell color to blue.
We're like, "Yeah, this one.
Let's crown it."
-This is my favorite --
Free Willy Award
for Animal Achievement,
Jenny the donkey.
-Oh, from
"Banshees of Inisherin."
-Had a big year.
Mickey Mouse.
Always good year.
-Big year for Mickey.
-The cast
of "The Secret Life of Pets,"
which I feel like
came out a while ago.
-Right.
But look, they've achieved.
-And then the winner
was tortoises, all.
-All tortoises.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, it does --
it makes sense
people were lined
around the block.
-Yes. You want to know.
You want to know.
There were big upsets.
I mean, Jenny the donkey
is probably really upset.
-I know. Jenny looked
at the nominees and was like,
"It's my year."
-"It's my year," but no.
-The good news for Jenny is
based on
"The Secret Life of Pets" cast,
Jenny might get nominated
10 years from now.
-Definitely, definitely.
-Don't give up.
-If Colin Farrell
can make a comeback,
so can Jenny.
-Yeah, that's true.
Pete Davidson
is hosting this week.
-Yes!
-Now that must be the first time
someone you worked with
has come back to host.
Is that --
-Yeah. That's true.
-That's a real passage of time.
I think maybe --
Well, probably for me
it was Will Ferrell.
Will Ferrell came back to host
and I was like, "Oh, my God.
We were cast members together."
And so what has it been like
for you with Pete back?
-It's been great.
It's so nice.
It's just nice to like have the
shorthand already with someone.
-Yeah.
-And we did our read-through
yesterday
and he -- we read
about like 35 sketches.
Right? And I think at the half,
at the break he said,
"This is more sketches
than I've been in
than my eight years
at this show."
[ Laughter ]
We were like,
"Maybe you're right."
-Five months out of the office.
Now, I guess you got a little --
you lost some shows on
the back end of the season,
but it was the summer
when people are away.
But, you know,
it was abbreviated year,
and maybe people left
a little bit quicker
than they would have.
What was the scene
like as everybody
went back to their offices?
-It was smelly.
-Yeah.
-It was smelly
because five months,
guess what's in the fridges.
Our takeout food from May.
-Yeah.
-And yeah, I think,
I still have a fruit cup
in my fridge down the hall
that has the whitest and
blackest mold I've ever seen.
-That's amazing.
-You know what? You don't just
do comedy, you do science.
And that's what I've always
respected about you.
I want to talk about
"Dicks: The Musical."
We'll be right back with more
from Bowen Yang.